I've learned more from failures and
insecurities and all sorts of things
that I've ever learned from successes in
life in the service Industries and
working at a grocery store midnight I
think those jobs taught me more about
working in Hollywood than almost
anything
I've ever done because you know
Hollywood you know you work with a lot
of people that that are you know not
necessarily accountable uh there's a
tremendous flexibility with uh uh people
who you know you could show up a weak
late and they'll just clap once you get
to set uh I think working those jobs
they taught me a real kind of steadfast
accountability I always sort of felt
like if I'm five minutes early I'm
already 10 minutes late and I'm telling
you that's like half of the good things
that have come to me have been about
being Super Hyper accountable and that
also creates a kind of infuses some
gratitude for the position that you're
in and understanding the position that
you're in and sort of a fleeting thing
it doesn't uh last and
um so you know I those jobs taught me a
lot I mean we're gonna Safeway we're
gonna that that that bar if you're 15
minutes late you're fired just see that
you know a lot of attention good and bad
is probably not great for anybody some
people thrive on it some people really
handle it very well well and and
integrated into who they are in a way
that works incredibly well um and then
other people don't you know I've seen
movie stars with giant air quotes that
that uh you know it's it's really been
one of the more devastating things that
have ever happened to them my highest
goal in Show Business was to be the
wacky neighbor in a sitcom quite
literally like if I had go to Los
Angeles I started an improv comedy if I
could go to Los Angeles I could get a
job as the wacky neighbor in a sitcom I
would be set that was all I ever really
wanted so everything else that's
happened and it's all happened quite
slowly has been a kind of an aggregate
if you want to call it fame or anything
it's always been very slow I didn't
become totally dysfunctional by
Hollywood which is you know something
that that I don't know if it speaks to
my character but it's easy for that to
happen yeah see I've saw I've been doing
it for 25 years I've seen it happen all
around me so
um it's a tough thing man when you're
when you're in the spotlight in any way
to kind of keep your keep your stuff
together so yeah I've had anxiety my
whole life really and
um you know it's there's a I feel like I
have two parts of my personality that
one takes over when that happens when I
would go out on like Letterman back in
the day I would always be nervous but I
remember I'd be standing backstage
before the curtain would open and I
would I would think to myself I'm gonna
die I'm literally going to die here or
the curtain's gonna open and I'm just
going to be I'm just going to be a
symphony of vomit just like something
horrible is going to happen but as soon
as that curtain opens and this happens
in my work a lot too it's like this
little guy takes over and he's like I
got this
I feel like my heart rate dropped and my
breathing calm and I just kind of go out
and I'm this different person no matter
how many years you do something you
don't get jaded you're passionate about
it you love it and it spoke to so much
of what I love about this industry even
though it's very easy to find so many
things that are detestable about it
there's there's truly great people that
work and artists and people that are you
know living breathing human beings not
just sort of products that we've created
um I just love that that to me was a
huge lesson
vulnerability is
beautiful and strong weirdly even the
strength to some people might be an
athament to vulnerability I think like
there's you know you can't really have
one without the other it's so easy to
blame yourself or to blame something
else and it's actually that idea of
leading with vulnerability and admitting
that just because you're the father
doesn't necessarily mean you know what's
best to be able to start conversations
from a place of openness and not knowing
and vulnerability is a huge honor I
think we're sort of entering an age
where you know people who don't talk
about the same my father's generation
they never talked about mental health or
what was going on inside it was just
bottle it up and you know and and
the younger generations and hopefully
the the you know my kids and their kids
will you know have have more open
dialogues about this kind of stuff but
it's sort of that's that's kind of the
way out is to feel I always found like
when you feel like you're not alone it's
something for some reason you
can recover a lot faster you can see the
light a little bit faster
um but when you feel like a lot of
people do they feel like they're
completely alone and that's the worst
feeling on Earth so talking about it
kind of to a certain degree sheds a
little sliver of light in there I think
that's important I think as a father I
really could understand that feeling of
impotence you have sometimes
when you you know you love and know your
kid more than anyone but you actually
don't always know the answers
particularly when it comes to issues of
mental health you start to kind of
become your own worst critic so you you
know most of the time I'm being hard on
myself and I was like a real introvert
as a kid I did not like school I did not
like the social pressures and the
Dynamics
yeah I think I think my 12 year old self
would be proud of me because I do this
thing in a way that has some Integrity I
I like to thank uh that 12 year old
would look at where I'm at and I'm you
know
we're doing all right I think
we need friends
along the way they're really leading
through that vulnerability May soon the
possibility of really attending out of
understanding and advised with those
people around you to walk with their
shoes and and have real honestly never
worry aligned
that we're all in the same but that this
mental health issues is a crisis
everywhere in the world and no one has a
beautiful everybody knows somebody is
always closer this is something that we
need to talk about you know part of why
I've been successful I think in my
business life is is being somewhat
self-aware and I understand
the idea that when you extract a lot
from a system you need to put back it
put some back in as well so um part of
it comes from that I can't you know
safely say that I would enjoy my
position in life if I wasn't sharing it
um you know it's not just sharing wealth
but also sharing power and stepping
aside where appropriate as well
um and you can do all these things and
you know at the end of the day like
you're still doing all right you know it
doesn't change you know much for your
own personal situation other than it
really feels great
[Music]